[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a south korean fantasy comedy
film called the dude in me
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the protagonist of the film is the heir
of the hanho group and a well-known
elite gangster pansu in the beginning we
are introduced to his lavish lifestyle
and loveless marriage to sio yan pansu
only married her because her father mr
han is the president of the hanho group
and an influential man sio yan is rich
and spoiled and hasn't worked a day in
her life but she still feels entitled to
her husband and father's money she
complains that her father is refusing to
buy her a gallery that she really wanted
pansu ignores her ridiculous demand and
goes on about his day in the office he
is informed of a carpenter who is
refusing to evacuate his shop that needs
to be destroyed for pansu's next project
to get the job done he invites his
right-hand man mr bang and asks him to
get the carpenter out one way or another
meanwhile the carpenter john key is
nervous knowing that the thugs will use
force to make him evacuate his fears
become reality when mr bang comes to his
shop and threatens to cut his arm off if
he doesn't sign the papers with no way
out the poor man gives up his shop the
next day pansu decides to go to an old
ramen shop that used to be his favorite
restaurant back in the day alongside him
a high school student dong hyun is also
enjoying the noodles dong hyun tries to
pay but finds out that he forgot his
wallet when he apologizes to the
restaurant's owner she forgives him and
claims that pansu will pay for him out
of generosity the gangster is outraged
by the bold lady but doesn't mind paying
for the kid even though he ate four
bowls of ramen the shop owner promises
to give him a special gift in return for
his generosity a while later dong hyun
is on the edge of a two-story building
trying to retrieve a shoe from a pole as
he reaches for it he loses his balance
and falls on top of pansu who happens to
be standing right below when pansu opens
his eyes again he finds himself on a
hospital bed a young nurse calls him a
student and talks to him informally
confused he walks outside and is
horrified to see his body lying down on
another hospital bed before he can react
the carpenter zhang ki launches at him
calling him his son a confused pansu
looks into the mirror to finally realize
that he has swapped bodies with the shy
kid from earlier it's freaky friday for
gangsters coincidentally john key who he
threatened to kill the previous day is
donghyun's father when pansu acts
differently than his normal self and
refuses to recognize his father the
doctor declares that he has something
called retrograde amnesia pansu then
recollects what the restaurant owner
told him earlier and runs to meet her
again however by then the restaurant is
being closed and the woman is nowhere to
be found in the following scene we are
introduced to pansu's business rival mr
yang yang hears the news about him being
in a coma he is over the moon and plans
to take advantage of the situation to
kill pansu at night pansu returns home
to his wife who thinks he is an intruder
he tries to explain the situation but
sio yan calls the security and makes
them kick him out of the house kind of
amazing that he thought that karen was
going to hear him out he is then taken
to the police station and accused of
trespassing his poor father is
distressed because of his outrageous
behavior thankfully for him the police
let pansu free without much fuss because
he's underaged in the following scene
pansu tries to wake up his body that's
in a coma desperate to get his body back
he jumps on top of dong hyun just then
his right hand man mr bang enters the
room and stops him pantsu tries to make
him understand that it's him trapped in
a kid's body but bang thinks he is
bluffing and kicks him out of the room
after being disrespected by his own
employees pansu returns to donghyun's
home with his father the place is too
small for his liking but he has a
hundred more problems to tend to junkie
cooks him a plethora of dishes to
accelerate his recovery initially pansu
says that he doesn't eat like a glutton
but a while later the plates are all
empty he realizes that even though his
mind is different he is still in
donghyun's body which affects his
appetite zhang ki believes that donghyun
was bullied into walking on the edge of
the building which resulted in the
accident the next day he goes to meet
his school principal when asked about
the bullying the principal claims that
nothing of such sort happens in their
school pansu sees through his lies and
is determined to find out what exactly
caused the accident as soon as he enters
the classroom a group of boys make fun
of him and flip him off pansu instantly
registers that donghyun was an introvert
who is made fun of all the time he
should get mr bang to cut those dicks
arms off during the lunch break a girl
named hyunjong is also being bullied by
popular kids they mix her food with a
cold drink and make her eat it
eventually they dump the entire plate of
food on her pansu calls them out for it
angering the leader of the bullies
taiwuk before pansu can showcase his
fighting skills the teachers arrive and
taiwuk has to retreat after school the
bullies stop pansu again and try to
intimidate him in turn he slaps them all
with zero effort and simply walks away
later that day the bullies trouble
another guy in the washroom just then
pansu comes out from a stall and helps
the poor guy he also takes taiwuk's
phone away promising to return it the
next day the bullies are so scared that
they let him do whatever he wants while
going through the phone pansu sees a
video of the day the accident took place
it is revealed that ty wuk and his group
had bullied dong hyun into getting on
the edge they are the reason he fell off
the building and their bodies exchanged
the next day taiwuk's leader is beating
him up for giving pansu his phone that
has the video on it pansu arrives and
kindly asks the leader to never trouble
anyone again blackmailing him with the
video the bully has no choice but to
agree somewhere else pansu's wife sio
yan takes advantage of her husband's
comatose state and starts dating younger
men pansu's rival mr yang gets a hint of
this and blackmails her into joining
hands with him the two together plan
pansu's downfall that night pansu goes
to the hospital and meets mr bang he
tells bang everything about his past and
proves his identity the following day
hyunjiang bumps into him and drops her
stuffed toy he follows her to return it
and happens to meet her mother me son to
panseu's utter shock me-sun is his first
love who he left to marry his current
wife he calls her by her first name
which surprises me son after pansu runs
away he remembers how he and me son used
to spend their days together when they
were young when he meets hyunjiang the
next time he takes some of her hair to
use for a parental dna test the results
come out and pansu finds out that
hyunjiang is actually his daughter
following that he goes to meet me son
and subtly asks her about her life she
tells him that she raised hyunjiang all
on her own because her father was not a
good person pansu feels awful that the
people he loves had to go through so
much because of his absence somewhere
else his current wife sio yan goes to
her father with fake reports of pansu
misusing the company's money in reality
she was told to do so by pansu's rival
mr yang her father believes her and
starts to consider removing pansu from
the company once he gets out of the coma
somewhere else pansu goes to a gym to
lose weight and to get closer to his
daughter who is learning self-defense in
the same institution i don't like the
way this is going initially she is
skeptical and is about to leave but mr
bang pretends to be the instructor and
convinces her to stay starting that day
the father and daughter train together
and begin getting along well eventually
pansu loses weight and gets fit the
girls in the school including the
bullies are surprised by his new persona
during the lunch break hyunjiang's
bullies stop her again but this time she
teaches them a lesson and defends
herself efficiently the other students
are stunned to witness her new newfound
confidence
that evening pansu goes to misun's
restaurant again while talking she
mentions her former lover who she wishes
she could have killed pansu realizes she
is talking about him and chokes on his
water me-sun is helping a perverted
customer when he touches her
inappropriately an enraged pansu asks
her to go inside and fights the perverts
me son suddenly stops him inquiring why
he's acting out of character pansu sits
her down and finally tells her
everything about switching bodies with
dong hyun initially she doesn't believe
him but pansu challenges her to ask him
anything that he would know when he
answers all the questions correctly
misun is in shock still she asks him to
go away from their lives as he did all
those years ago a flashback shows us
young me son and pansu meeting for the
first time he rudely informed her that
he was getting married to his boss's
daughter and asked me son to forget him
the following day a popular guy from the
school named min ho invites hyunjiang to
his birthday party hyunjiang who has
never been called to a party excitedly
agrees to come unaware of minho's actual
intentions after that pansu and me son
meet at a restaurant where she bluntly
tells him that she doesn't want him in
their lives he tries to win her over and
kisses her in front of everyone the
people around them are shocked because
to them pansu is half of me son's age
she pushes him away and slaps him in the
face still pansu doesn't stop and
follows her outside suddenly he gets a
call from his friend who informs him
about the bully's plan to trouble
hyunjiang at the party pansu quickly
rushes to the party and arrives there to
see minho pouring a bowl of alcohol on
hyunjiang angered to see his daughter
crying he fights all of the guys who are
surrounding her the girls who witness
the fight fall head over heels for him
hyunjiang also takes a stand against min
ho and kicks him into the pool after
that the father and daughter leave the
following day mr bang informs pansu that
his wife is conspiring to remove him
from hanho's list of potential heirs
pansu writes a letter to his
father-in-law mr han and asks mr bang to
deliver it to him later that day pansu
is walking down the street when one of
the girls from his class asks him out he
claims that he doesn't date schoolgirls
right after hyunjung arrives and asks
him the same question horrified pansu
tells her that he can never date her and
walks away thank god at home misun also
finds out that her daughter wants to
date her father she orders hyunjiang to
stay away from him at night pansu's
rival yang breaks into the hospital to
kill dong hyun just as he is about to do
so dong hyun wakes up out of the blue
startled yang runs away after waking
from the coma donghyun finds himself in
a strange body and runs to his father
john key thinks he is an intruder and is
about to call the police when pansu
returns home he explains everything to
john key who is still skeptical but
agrees to believe them because he's a
fan of lindsay lohan following that
pansu asks for donghyun's help to solve
things with me son the two go to her
restaurant and pretend to have returned
to their own bodies as dong hyun
apologizes to her as pansu yang and his
men come to the restaurant he had
followed donghyun from the hospital and
is here to kill him once and for all
donghyun cries begging them for his life
surprising yang in his group pansu sends
me son and dong hyun to another room and
himself fights the thugs but this time
they have come prepared for his attacks
suddenly me son comes out and opens a
gas cylinder threatening to blow up the
entire place yang and his men have no
choice but to run away due to the chaos
misun finds out that the guys were lying
earlier still she talks to dong hyun as
pansu and tells him about the hardships
she faced because of his absence the two
hug in the end somewhere else mr han has
found out that his daughter lied to get
her husband in trouble and hide the fact
that she has an extramarital affair han
disowns her and refuses to give her an
inheritance he also asks pansu to meet
him instantly since pansu cannot go in
front of them himself donghyun goes in
his place with a microchip in his ears
the chip works fine for a few minutes
but when han asks him about his second
family it turns off with no one to
communicate to donghyun is alone to make
pansu's decisions for him he says that
after returning from the hospital he
realized that family is the most
important thing in the world hence he is
removing himself from the hanho group to
be with his family han respects his
decision and lets him go when dong hyun
returns to the car pansu hugs him
thanking him for doing the right thing
but their happiness doesn't last long
when an enraged ceo yawn hits them with
her car pansu is severely injured and
has to be taken to the hospital as he is
talking to his family on his deathbed
donghyun falls unconscious in the
following scene pansu is in an operation
theater his surgeon is the same woman
who caused the body swap initially she
asks him if he liked the gift and
changes him back to normal six months
later dong hyun in his own body returns
to school everyone respects him and is
nice to him he and hyunjiang have
started dating wow i've never seen a dad
wingman that hard meanwhile pansu has
bought a better place for me son to run
her restaurant all of them including
john key and mr bang work for her as
employees
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching